like you've had michael pollan on the
show before he wrote that Omnivore's
Dilemma and in it he was just said
basically and I'm paraphrasing but he
said it honey is so different from the
inside than this from the outside yes so
easy to view honey in the lens of like
there's a dude sitting behind a deer
smiling and grabbing its antlers there's
also the problem that malnutrition in
this country is almost non-existent fat
people are poor people in this country
yes [ __ ] like poor people are fat yeah
which is one of the weirder things about
our society this is never hurt this has
never happened in the history of human
beings that the poor people were the big
fat ones I got cell phones I mean
there's a lot of rich people that are
fat too don't get me wrong but there's
it's people don't have a problem being
fat sure right and this doesn't mean
that there's not a lot of malnutrition
there most certainly is
but it's nutrition it's not it's not a
lack of calories lack of calories was a
massive problem throughout most of you
more history the lack lack of food so
it's the the access to food is so normal
to us it's so easy but the unfettered
access to food is what's really normal
now yeah that's what's changed with
industrialization and come fast fast
food is processed food is [ __ ] yeah
and if you go back to when people when
hunting was more normal in the 1920s or
the 1930s it was really normal there's
also no fast food yeah so when you would
get a roast even if you went into a
butcher and you got a roast and you
brought it home and you were making
roast beef and you're cooking it or your
uncle shot a deer milk was delivered to
your door yeah not my dad you know so
there's a lot of different is wrong is
wrong yeah so there's a lot of different
yeah like the the removal from the
actual you know process that hunters go
through but it actually it might not
have been wrong like when they start
pasteurizing marginalization that's a
Jamie thing that was a Louie pest or
that's that is who it was Esther ization
right that's that's what it came from
yeah yeah um when they start
implementing that like when you would
get the milk on your door in those glass
jars
that milk go bad quick though but that's
me you know my grandparents that's what
they would describe the milkman these
1880s it's when it started
that's what started I wonder when it was
common I wonder if it was but you think
about like market hunting we always talk
about hunting like the the turn of the
century being this huge moment and
hunting conservation market hunting
really became a thing when when it
accelerated when refrigeration became a
reality
right and accelerated when railroads
could take meat from the Great American
West back to the cities in the East
Coast hmm so those things like
accelerated technology and those things
accelerated market hunting and the the
depredation of things like the
white-tailed deer and the Buffalo as we
all famously